Why can't Sharkboy breathe underwater? And
why would supposedly valiant heroes steal
cookies? Here are a few things
about "The Adventures of Sharkboy
and Lavagirl" that people only seem
to think about once they've grown up.
In the mid-2000s, Robert Rodriguez was
arguably at the height of his powers.
The Texas-born filmmaker had gone from
producing "El Mariachi" for a mere seven
thousand dollars in 1992 to developing beloved
hits like "Desperado," "From Dusk Till Dawn,"
and of course, the "Spy Kids" films. However,
"The Adventures of Sharkboy and Lavagirl" was
undeniably a low point in the director's career.
Even the most inane, toilet-humor-based kids
movies will often throw in some jokes for the
parents. "Sharkboy and Lavagirl," however,
is aimed squarely at the kids — and that's
because it was partially written by one. The
opening titles of "Sharkboy and Lavagirl"
introduce it as "a Rodriguez family movie,"
based on the dreams of then-7-year-old
Racer Max Rodriguez, who also played
young Sharkboy in the opening scene.
The adults in the movie, although played
by household-name actors like George Lopez,
David Arquette, and Kristin Davis, still deliver
stiff, awkward dialogue that sounds like a child's
idea of the way an adult might speak. For
an adult hoping for action like "Desperado,"
a compelling narrative like "Sin City," or
special effects like "Alita: Battle Angel,"
"Sharkboy and Lavagirl" is certainly one
of the less compelling Rodriguez films.
The word "dream" — or some variation of it
— is uttered a total of 188 times throughout
"Sharkboy and Lavagirl's" 93-minute run time.
That means the word is being said, on average,
once every thirty seconds — but in some
scenes, it's much more often than that.
Even by the fiftieth time, it still isn't very
clear what the movie has to say about dreams,
other than that they're a good thing to have.
Young Max is mocked by his classmates for
reading stories about Sharkboy and Lavagirl from
his dream journal — but then, his dreams turn
out to be real, so Linus and the other kids
learn that dreams are good because… they can
become real? But Max's dream almost destroys the
school, and that doesn't sound very good at all.
There's also the matter of Max's parents.
His father is an unemployed writer,
and his inability to get a reliable job has
pushed his parents to the brink of divorce.
At the film's climax, rather than
finding some sort of mature compromise,
the pair have a near-death discussion where they
remind each other that they're best friends,
reconciling without actually resolving the issue
at hand. Rather than have Max's father figure
out a way to follow his dreams while still
supporting his family, the movie just… ends.
"Sharkboy and Lavagirl" makes such a
repetitive point about the importance
of dreaming that it seems like it should actually
have something to say by the end of it. Instead,
all this talk of dreams eventually
starts to sound more like a nightmare.
"The Adventures of Sharkboy and Lavagirl" is, on
the one hand, refreshingly colorful and vivid.
During a time when even kid-targeted action
movies were slowly inching towards gloomy,
dystopian franchises like "The Maze
Runner" and "The Hunger Games," the
colorful world of Drool stood out as a
unique vision. On the other hand, when
an adult watches "Sharkboy and Lavagirl," they
see a film drunk on its own greenscreen power,
one that makes you wonder how it could
have possibly cost $50 million to produce.
At the time of the film's release in
2005, CGI was being used more and more in
all sorts of movies, but the technology was
at the end of an awkward transitional phase.
"Sharkboy and Lavagirl" was shot almost entirely
in front of a green screen — and it shows,
with its more fantastical settings resembling
a Windows screensaver more than a major motion
picture. That's not to say that CGI-heavy movies
can't be good — 1982's "TRON" and 2008's "Speed
Racer" are both underrated gems — but as an
adult watching "Sharkboy and Lavagirl" in 2021,
it's hard to not be distracted by visual effects
less sophisticated than an Instagram filter.
Additionally, the 3D technology
used for "Sharkboy and Lavagirl"
made for a good selling point, but did
little to actually make the film look good.
"Sharkboy and Lavagirl" utilized anaglyph 3D — the
kind that uses those red and blue glasses — which
just made the movie look even worse on the big
screen. As Roger Ebert put it in his review,
"Fully three quarters of the movie is in
'3'-D, which looks more like 1-D to me,
removing the brightness and life of the
movie's colors and replacing them with a drab,
listless palette, which is about as exciting
as looking at a 3-D bowl of oatmeal."
In 2005, George Lopez was at the top of his
game. He was gearing up for the fifth season
of his highly-rated sitcom "George Lopez,"
he'd made cameos in shows like "Curb Your
Enthusiasm," and he'd established himself
as a well-respected stand-up comedian.
In "Sharkboy and Lavagirl," Lopez fully commits to
his dual role as Max's teacher Mr. Electricidad,
as well as one of the chief bad
guys on Planet Drool, Mr. Electric.
Both roles are over the top, of course,
and Lopez mostly pulls them off.
Highlights include his demand for Max
and his bully to be friends as a teacher,
or his constant spouting of electricity-based
puns as a floating orb with claws for hands.
"Hey, watts up? You know, watts!"
But why did George Lopez also have to
provide a voiceover for Max's childhood robot
Tobor? Following the success of films
like "Aladdin" and "Shrek," Hollywood
had developed something of an obsession
with casting movie stars in voice roles,
largely ignoring an entire industry of
talented voice professionals who had
been providing their talents to cartoons
and animated movies for decades prior.
So, rather than finding the perfect voice actor
to design an endearing identity for Tobor around,
the audience gets George Lopez again — and
yet again for a fourth time as a guardian
of the Ice Princess. Robert Rodriguez
himself even voices a talking shark,
further trading creativity for
mediocre, uninspired stunt casting.
Out of everyone in "Sharkboy
and Lavagirl," it's clear that
future "Twilight" heartthrob Taylor
Lautner is the actor who possesses
"it," that indefinable quality that
makes a movie star, well, a movie star.
When production on the film began,
Lautner was just 12 years old. He already
had an extensive martial arts background,
earning a black belt by age 8 and appearing
in a national karate tournament in 2003.
Lautner was the first and only actor
to audition for the role of Sharkboy:
Rodriguez was truly convinced he
was perfect from the very beginning.
Sure enough, Lautner's Sharkboy is a glowering
menace: he never stops moving and rages easily,
snarling and yelling without holding back. He
plays an important role in the most standout
action scene of the film, using his martial arts
skills in an elaborate fight with Mr. Electric's
dog-like cord monsters. Rodriguez even asked
Lautner to choreograph his own fight scenes.
Lautner also takes center stage for one of
the most bizarre and memorable moments of
"Sharkboy and Lavagirl:" a ridiculous,
inexplicably aggressive lullaby that he
sings to get Max to fall asleep and dream
planet Drool back to its rightful shape.
He busts impressive dance moves while
sing-yelling all sorts of absurd lines.
It's a shame that Taylor Lautner couldn't
return for "We Can Be Heroes," the 2020
quasi-sequel to "Sharkboy and Lavagirl," as he
was undoubtedly the true star of the original.
You'd think that the whole point
of having elements of Max's dream
world echo elements of Max's real
world would be to illuminate his
relationships with the people and things
that surround him. Lavagirl, for example,
asks Max why he made her Sharkboy's partner
when they're, quote, "not compatible" — the
same words Max's mother used to describe why
she and Max's father are not getting along.
Such moments could, if properly
and somewhat clearly presented,
give a film like this greater depth.
Unfortunately, Sharkboy and Lavagirl
breeze past the questions as quickly as they
bring it up. The additional presence of Max's
parents as cookie-hungry giants on planet Drool
just serves to make things even more confusing.
Then there's Mr. Electricidad, who allows his
daughter Marissa to face off against a giant
robot with his own face on it. While
the idea of a girl facing off against
an imaginary construct of her own father
seems like it could be rich with symbolism,
such moments don't seem to
connect to any greater theme,
other than revolving around a loose, Freudian
concept of dreams being inherently meaningful.
"The Adventures of Sharkboy and Lavagirl"
has a few off-putting attempts at the sort of
wink-wink adult humor other children's movies
sometimes tackle with wit and subtlety. Here,
however, they come across as awkward at
best, and just plain confusing at worst.
At one point, Sharkboy says he's heard that
the Ice Princess is the "most beautiful girl
on the planet," causing Lavagirl to
get jealous and zap him in the butt
with her lava powers. Other moments
include Mr. Electricidad's insistence
that Max stays away from his daughter, and
Linus' reaction to Lavagirl burning his desk.
"She's hot!"
[shredding paper]
During moments like these, it feels like you
can see remnants of a screenplay with jokes
intended for adults, but they're ultimately more
half-baked than the cookies in Max's kitchen.
In "We Can Be Heroes," it is revealed that
the pair eventually got together and had a
child of their own. At some point, it seems that
what was once implied has now become explicit.
It might seem like a minor detail, but early on in
"Sharkboy and Lavagirl," Max wakes up to find that
the cookies his mom baked and left in the kitchen
have been strangely consumed. One of the cookies
has jagged, shark-like teeth marks in it, while
the other is burnt and remains hot to the touch.
His parents, of course, don't believe
his repeated insistence that it wasn't
him who ate the baked treats — and
clearly, judging from the evidence,
it was Sharkboy and Lavagirl. It's not until
the next day that the duo reveal themselves as
real heroes, recruiting Max to help them
save planet Drool while he's asleep in class.
As cute as the scene might be, it also begs a
question: Why bother sneaking into his house
the night before they were going to contact
him anyway? Are the heroes like Santa Claus?
Did they think it would be funny
to get Max into trouble? Not only
has Max seemingly discovered that Sharkboy
and Lavagirl are real, but in this scene,
he also learns that they have no
issues with chocolate chip thievery.
After he wraps up his battle with Minus on
Drool, Lavagirl tells Max to blink three times,
which will take him home — much like
Dorothy clicking her heels together
in "The Wizard of Oz." When he does
so, he wakes up back in his classroom,
implying that a large portion of what
we've just seen was a dream of some sort.
But during that "dream," Max fell asleep and
had another dream inside of that dream. Is that
even possible? It seems like "The Adventures of
Sharkboy and Lavagirl" is a lot like "Inception,"
but without Leonardo DiCaprio patiently explaining
how things work. There are dreams within dreams,
and then those dreams intrude on what you thought
was reality all along. Like dreams themselves,
the whole thing is as impossible to
follow as it is to explain to anyone else.
This is yet another nitpick, but it's the sort of
thing that can really nag an adult. Up until the
very last battle on Drool, it is made abundantly
clear that Sharkboy possesses the abilities of,
well, a shark. After being lost at
sea, Sharkboy was raised by sharks,
growing sharp teeth, fins, and gills
as he adapted to the shark lifestyle.
However, in the big showdown
with Mr. Electricidad,
electric eels get the better of
Sharkboy, nearly causing him to drown.
You know, because sharks have to
watch out, or they could drown.
"Can he survive down there?"
"He can hold his breath, but not forever.
He'll drown if I don't go get him."
What about the gills that we saw all up and
down his sides, at the beginning of the film?
It's an example of a screenplay giving a character
a newfound limitation, simply because it is
called for at that particular moment to build
dramatic tension. It's also frustratingly lazy.
Nearly two decades later, "The Adventures of
Sharkboy and Lavagirl" continues to hold a
special place in the hearts of those
who discovered it as kids. However,
thanks to all sorts of bizarre moments and
choices, you'd probably be doing yourself a favor
to keep the movie in your memories rather than
revisiting it on your streaming site of choice.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.